here's the 21st century Howard Hughes
john d rockefeller and steve jobs all
rolled into one dynamic package his
hunger for global change mirrors the
sense of adventure of the great
explorers of the past his ideas
considered crazy by everyone around him
have opens up new frontiers as he
continues to improve the world with the
aid of technological advancement his
goal to make the earth a better place to
live on has expanded to encompass the
entire universe including the
possibility of supporting human life on
Mars
in this episode of buying graphics we
get up close and personal with the man
who was the model for Marvel's Iron Man
movie franchise character Tony Stark
of course the man were talking about
must be Elon Musk Elon Musk was born on
June the 28th for 1971 in Pretoria South
Africa his Canadian born mother was a
dietitian with his father being a
mechanical and electrical engineer
the boy has a natural leaning towards
technology buying his first computer a
Commodore vic-20 with money you'd saved
when he was just 10 years old by the age
of 12 he had created his own video game
blaster which he sold for $500 as a
preteen it already taught himself
computer programming Musk's life came to
a crossroads in his late teens when he
was faced with compulsory military
service in South Africa while he had no
problem with the thought of serving his
country in uniform he was repulsed by
the idea of being a part of a system
that suppressed the country's indigenous
black people his desire was to get to
America the land of opportunity
especially in regard to his growing
fascination with all things related to
computer technology to do so however he
figured he would have to use Canada as a
stepping stone his mother was still a
Canadian citizen and so steps were taken
for along to acquire Canadian
citizenship for himself
after graduating from Pretoria boys high
school B emigrated Canada in June of
1989 aged just 17 he had hardly any
money men's new real connections turning
up on the doorsteps of distant relatives
of his mother and being put to work on
their farm as well as tending vegetables
and shoveling grain he got a job at a
lumber mill cleaning out boilers
then he managed to secure a job as an
intern clerk at a local bank in 1990 he
moved to Kingston Ontario where he began
a science degree at the Queen's
University two years later he was able
to achieve his goal of living in the
United States transferring his studies
to the University of Pennsylvania within
two more years he graduated with double
degrees in science and business it was
around this time that must came across a
copy of Douglas Adams as Booker
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy the
book revolves around a supercomputer
which is built to figure out the
ultimate answer to the question of life
the universe and everything after 7.5
million years of computing it spits out
the answer the number 42 along with that
answered the computer which can talk and
some sage advice telling the Inquirer
the problem with you to be quite honest
with you is that you never really know
what the question is for mask reading
that was a light bulb moment he later
recalled it highlighted an important
point which is that a lot of times the
question is harder than the answer by
the time he emerged from university musk
wasn't entirely sure what the questions
were but he knew that they were tied up
in three key areas the internet clean
energy and outer space in 1995 musk
enrolled himself in a ph.d program for
energy physics at Stanford University
yet after an attendance of just two days
he decided to drop out in order to
launch his first business his love of
physics it never wavered but he saw
greater opportunities in the burgeoning
internet revolution a way to make
society better and himself ripchat
musk realized that as more and more
companies established an online presence
they would need to have their printed
materials converted into digital
documents if he could fill that need he
would be on to a winner
Elan teamed up with his younger brother
Kimball to develop content publishing
software designed for news and media
companies at a time when many venture
capitalists had never even heard of the
Internet it was a major risk the
products that the musk brothers came up
with all that was called zip - it
started life as a tool that would help
people to search for maps and directions
on the internet with people also being
able to post information through
something similar to a micro blogging
system things they were tough for musk
in these early days he had no money not
even enough to rent an office and an
apartment at the same time so in order
to combat this he rented an office where
he slept on a futon and took care of his
personal hygiene down at the local why
starting with small newspapers musk was
able to quickly grow his client base
agreements were made with large media
companies including the Chicago Tribune
and the New York Times in order to allow
those companies to use zip to to make
their content readily available to
readers via the Internet the program was
used by many similar companies along
with e-commerce sites as a platform for
their web presence by 1999 the zip2
corporation was providing web hosting
web development and maintenance services
for close to 200 websites they came to
the attention of the online city guide
citysearch who were interested in a
merger this deal didn't work out but
another one did after just four years of
operation the zip2 corporation was sold
to Compaq computers for 307 million
dollars in cash and a further 34 million
in stock options at the age of just 28
Elon Musk he was a multi-millionaire but
he was just getting started and even
before the ink was dry on the zip to
deal he had thrown himself into his next
venture and that was X comma Musk's
vision was to create the world's first
online bank and he invested ten million
dollars to kick it off the goal was to
offer every service that you could get
from a can
Bank but with the added benefit that you
could send and receive money securely
using only your email address XCOM was
an immediate success after just a year
of operation it was merged with a money
transfer system called con Finity the
combines businesses were renamed PayPal
in 2001 now working with con Finiti
founders Peter Thiel and Max Levchin the
business dropped the idea of a fully
functional online bank and focused on
the feature that seemed to grab
everyone's attention the ability to send
money to and from anyone who had the
same app at this early stage the system
it relied on a windows-based handheld
device during the first months of the
merger from January 1999 to October of
2000 musk was CEO of X : during this
time he set up this viral system that
grew it into the world's largest email
payment processor new customers they
were offered a $20 cash card along with
an additional $10 for referring a
friends within two months more than a
hundred thousand new customers had come
on board but not all was well within the
company's management
the problem was masks management style
which couldn't best be described as
dictatorial both feel and Levchin found
it difficult to work with him they were
especially frustrated at his need to
micromanage everything disputes and
divisions arose over which technologies
to use and how to brand the company as a
result of such divisions Thiel and
legend organized coup against CEO mask
while he was meeting with prospective
customers overseas he returned to the
country to discover that he had been
fired as CEO by the board and replaced
by Peter Thiel shortly thereafter the
name of the company was changed to
PayPal this time with a second capital P
from there it grew exponentially leading
to a buyout by eBay in 2002 the cost of
the sale was a staggering 1.5 billion
dollars as the largest shareholder must
walked away with a cool 165 million
dollars even before PayPal was sold musk
was on to his next business venture ever
since he was a child he had been
fascinated by space exploration he had
always been an avid science fiction
reader band now he had the money to turn
science fiction into reality
he was convinced that the earth was
destined to collapse as a
sustaining planet the sooner we started
working on the technology required in
interplanetary travel and sustaining
life beyond Earth the better in
discussions with a friend one day musk
complains that despite the vast
improvements in the technology industry
the space industry has lagged
sorrowfully behinds since man have set
foot on the moon way back in 1969 it
appeared to him that no meaningful
progress had been made he was determined
to change that in his third company
Space Exploration Technologies or SpaceX
was to be his platform to do it a major
goal of SpaceX is to create a space
vehicle that can take people equipment
and other necessary resources to Mars
and build a transportation
infrastructure that will allow humans to
become a multiplanetary species when
musk lets the world in on his vision he
was immediately subjected to ridicule
industry experts dismissed him as a rich
bored playboy claiming that his physics
degree in previous business ventures
hardly made him qualified to
conceptualize develop and build rockets
however they were under estimating musk
it was not only a quick study but who
also brought onboard the best engineers
from top aerospace companies such as
Boeing TWA and NASA musk he was
disappointed that NASA seemed
disinterested in space exploration
he wanted to pique the public's interest
in order to encourage NASA to increase
their allocated funds to a project to
land a device on Mars and then build a
bubble bio verse he also wanted to
introduce a cheaper and safer
alternative to space shuttle travel he
was struck by the fact that the Russians
were able to reduce rockets that were
cheaper and safer than anything that the
Americans could come out with he
traveled to Russia in an attempt to
purchase a refurbished ICBM but the deal
became too complicated musk next set his
sights on creating and successfully
launching a reusable rocket which he
called Falcon one the idea was that it
could fly off to space return to Earth
and then be launched back to space again
the first scheduled launch for Falcon 1
was in 2005 yet three years later after
multiple failed attempts Falcon 1 was
still to have its first successful
flight finally on its fourth attempt
Falcon 1 successfully launched on the
back of this success SpaceX was able to
secure a 1.6 billion dollar contract
from NASA involving 12 future flights on
their rocket Falcon 9 to the
International Space Station musk is
estimated that SpaceX is efforts
can minimize the US government's
expenses by around 1 billion dollars
every year mask has always been
fascinated by cars and specifically by
the dream of creating a breed of
electric cars that totally transform the
driving experience while he was still a
sophomore at university he had become
aware of the world's depleting resources
what was needed was an alternative
source of fuel one that would not
produce carbon emissions that were
damaging the environment it was from
these ideas that musk decided to pursue
electric cars a year after launching
SpaceX musk was introduced to Alcoa and
Tom gage of AC propulsion the company
behind in all-electric car known as the
T zero musk was interested in mass
producing the T 0 but Ciccone engaged
showed no interest they did however
introduce musk to a group of men who
were dedicated to finding a more
environmentally friendly vehicle in July
of 2003 musk teamed up with three of
them ian rides marked happening and
Martin Eberhard to form the tesla
corporation this company was named in
recognition of the father of AC
induction motors Nikola Tesla from the
very beginning Tesla faced an uphill
battle the concept of an electric car
was years away from capturing the public
attention and just as was the case with
SpaceX the question was loudly asked how
a visionary with no experience in the
car industry could successfully
establish a new company and a new
product and stand against the industry
giants
what's more they were attempting to do
something that those industry giants had
simply been unable to do in fact Robert
Lutz CEO of General Motors stated that
lithium-ion technology for cars was at
least ten years into the future as a
result of the lack of industry
enthusiasm very few investors wanted
anything to do with Tesla in fact musk
had to funds the majority of the
operations of the company himself the
goal of having the first roadster
rolling off the assembly line by 2007
never materialized as costs just
continued to mount
just as with XCOM years earlier tensions
arose among the management's musk who
was chairman of the board has no faith
in Martin Eberhard the president of the
company before long ever heart had been
ousted and musk put himself in full
control
he was now the CEO of two startups and
even for a dynamo like Musk this was
still too much still he had to make both
companies work his master plan for Tesla
was to build a luxury electric sports
car along with a line of more affordable
cars with electric power and zero
emissions in 2008 the first roadster was
shipped out this $110,000 electric
sports car could run for 200 miles on a
single charge and was capable of going
from zero to 60 miles per hour in less
than four seconds the more affordable
electric car was called the Tesla Model
S its release began in June of 2012
sales took off and there are currently
500 rolling off the production line
every week as well as being the CEO of
Tesla musk is also the chairman of the
board of directors of another
environmental company Solar City well
not the founder of this company he is
very involved in achieving the company's
mission to deliver complete solar energy
systems to the end users without any of
the upfront fees it also promised
reduced utility bills for all of its
customers by offering free installation
and zero down payments to homeowners
musk has made it easier for consumers to
afford solar energy and has
revolutionized the way that the solar
industry is run so the city has enjoyed
tremendous growth and success with
clients that include eBay Walmart and
the US military this has made it the
number one solar power service provider
in the United States as if being an
industry leader in space travel electric
cars and solar power is not enough in
August of 2013
musk proposed a completely new mode of
personal transport he called it the
Hyperloop the concept will allow people
to travel between large cities at the
speed of sound allowing passengers to
get from San Francisco to Los Angeles in
about 30 minutes it involves a
vacuum-sealed pod that rides on top of
electromagnetic waves very simply this
is sort of similar to the way a surfers
board rides ocean waves the pods will
glide across the track at speeds of many
hundreds of miles per hour this
eliminates the problem of friction
created by wheels on tracks the same
month that musk unveiled plans for the
Hyperloop the crowdsourcing and
collaboration platform jump start fund
was
tablished comprised of more than a
hundred engineers developers and
investors the group took on Hyperloop as
their first project in 2014 they formed
a Hyperloop transportation technologies
and undertook a feasibility study in
musk ran a student competition to design
and build Hyperloop pods a SpaceX
sponsored mile long track was built in
order to run the pods on on July the
20th 2017 musk announced that he had
gained verbal government approval to
build a Hyperloop track between New York
City and Washington DC
Elon Musk is one guy who it is a
challenge to keep up with in the 12
months from December 2015 to December
he started no less than three companies
open AI a not-for-profit artificial
intelligence research company near
Lincoln gyro technology startup with the
aim of integrating the human brain with
AI and the boring company which aims to
bring down the cost of tunnel-boring by
ten fold in on musk has been married two
times he met his first wife Justine
Wilson while they were both students at
Queen's University in Ontario they tie
the knot in 2000 Justine is a fantasy
novelist who described her life with
Elon as a dream lifestyle there was
empty at the core her husband was so
focused on his work that even when he
was at home his mind didn't seem to be
there the marriage ended in 2008 in a
very messy public divorce enon and
Justine have five children together a
set of twins and a set of triplets
Mosca met his second wife to Luna Reilly
at a London nightclub they were married
just six weeks after he filed for a
divorce from Justine the wedding took
place at Skibo castle in scotland he was
39 and she was 23 things apparently
didn't go well with musk announcing
their separation just two years later on
Twitter it was an amazing four years I
will love you forever you will make
someone very happy one day the couple
they got back together in 2014 but the
divorce was finalized towards the end of
when it comes to the future of Elon Musk
the best advice is to watch this space
he has never backed down from his
ambition to travel to Mars and possibly
even retire there one day until that
happens we can be assured that he will
continue to revolutionize the way that
the world consumes energy benefits from
technology
into space so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please
do hit that thumbs up button below and
do not forget to subscribe for brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
also check out some of our previous
videos over there on the right and as
always thank you for watching